le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov et son
homologue libanais se sont rencontrés ce
matin est les deux hommes ont tenu une
conférence de presse on retrouve tout de
suite notre correspondante à moscou
maëlys d'estrées
enfin quels sujets étaient à l'ordre du
jour ce matin maëlys
bonjour sophy lors de leur rencontre les
ministres des affaires étrangères ont
bien sûr évoqué la coopération
bilatérale entre leurs pays mais
également la situation politique
actuelle au liban ainsi que la crise en
syrie à ce sujet sergueï lavrov a mis en
exergue l'attachement de la russie à
l'indépendance et à l'intégrité
territoriale du liban écoutez
nous avons parlé aussi de l'actualité
internationale régionale nos positions
sont très proches voire concordent
parfaitement
la situation toujours difficile
explosé sur certains points et nous
sommes convaincus que le liban ne doit
pas être
considérée comme un point d'ingérence
extérieure
je sais que des efforts dans des
finitions différentes sont faites sont
faits dans ce sens et je pense que cela
est mortifère tant pour le gouvernement
que nous libanais que pour la situation
régionale
et le liban ne doit pas servir à
d'autres pays pour que ceux-ci règlent
leurs comptes et bien évidemment nous
sommes contre le fait que ce pays se
trouve otage dans la crise autour de la
syrie de chefs de la diplomatie ont
également évoqué les réfugiés syriens
actuellement présents au liban dont
beyrouth et moscou espère le retour
rapide dans leur patrie sergueï lavrov a
par ailleurs annoncé que la russie avait
fourni aujourd'hui au liban des images
satellites de l'explosion survenue au
port de beyrouth le 4 août 2020 à la
demande du liban et afin de faire
avancer l'enquêté sur les causes de
l'accident les deux ministres ont
également discuté de la participation
d'entreprises russes à la restauration
du port de beyrouth
merci beaucoup moins lisse d'istres en
direct de moscou